man withstands one of the harshest
environments on Earth for a month and is
now sharing his tail he went missing in
late January in the Amazon rainforest in
Northern Bolivia he was found this week
battered and bruised butt alive Michael
George is here with how he was able to
Define nature and Michael George didn't
Define nature but this guy did and it's
an incredible story Michael good morning
Jeff good morning this is an incredible
Story of Survival Jonathan Acosta was
hunting with friends in the Amazon back
in January when he got separated he was
lost and alone in the jungle for a month
but somehow miraculously he survived
missing for a month Jonathan Acosta is
back in the arms of his family exhausted
but alive the 30 year old Bolivian cacao
farmer got lost in the Amazon on January
25th 30 long days later he was found by
search and rescue teams
a crowd gathered to watch him arrive at
the hospital he could barely stand as
his family helped him into a wheelchair
doctors gave him food water and medical
treatment
it's unbelievable I couldn't believe
that people were still looking for me
after all this time Acosta says he
survived by fighting off animal attacks
and drinking rain water and his own
urine local media reports he lost 37
pounds during his ordeal
I ate worms insects you have no idea
what I had to go through to survive all
these days I thank God very much I thank
him because he gave me a new life
outside acosta's family thanked those
who never gave up searching for him
I'm grateful to God I thank him and all
those who have helped us I thank you
from the bottom of my heart
and this is believed to be one of the
longest known cases of somebody
surviving alone in the Amazon and his
family says that after this he's giving
up hunting for good I can imagine 30
days it's incredibly drank rain water he
ate bugs and worms all he had was one
shotgun shell he had gone hunting and so
he had one shotgun shell and he managed
to make it it's like an episode of alone
wow incredible Michael thank you